Speaker 1: Well, it is happening again. Classified
items have been found at a Donald Trump storage
unit in Florida. It is the guy who said no one
respects classified information as much as he
does. He may have been a little bit careless
with the classified documents. Rolling Stone
reports classified documents found at Trump's
storage unit with swords and wrestling belts.
Lawyers for the former president turned over more
sensitive documents to the FBI after conducting an
independent search of his properties identified in
additional documents with classification markings
in a search that spanned three Trump properties,
including Bedminster, Golf, Trump Club in Jersey,
Trump Tower in New York, and presumably also Mar a
Lago down in Florida. The documents allegedly made
their way. Look at this. To the storage unit as
part of a £3,000 transport of miscellaneous items
shipped from Virginia to Florida. They're just
in a storage unit. They're like in a pod. It was
full of suits and swords and wrestling belts and
all sorts of things. A source told the Washington
Post, who asserted Trump had likely never even
been to the unit. Sources told The Post that
the material was turned over to the FBI, which
declined to supervise the searches. Those familiar
with the investigation also indicated to the Post
that classified materials were not recovered from
searches at Bedminster and Trump Tower only from
the storage unit. Trump has been obsessed with
people's handling of classified information for
years and years and years, and it turns out that
he is the worst. Remember all of this stuff?
Speaker 2: Okay, we're going to move.
Speaker 3: And yet she didn't know the word the
letter C on a document. Right. She didn't even
know what that word what that letter meant. You
know, it's amazing. I'm watching Hillary go over
facts and she's going after fact after fact and
she's lying again because she said she you know,
what she did with the emails was fine. You think
it was fine to delete 33,000 emails? I don't think
so. She said that 33,000 emails had to do with her
daughter's wedding, number one, and a yoga class.
Well, maybe we'll give three or three or four or
five or something. 33,000 emails deleted, and now
she's saying there wasn't anything wrong. And more
importantly, that was after getting a subpoena.
That wasn't before. That was after she got it from
the United States Congress. And I'll be honest,
I am so disappointed in Congressman.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So Hillary. Very,
very untrustworthy. How about George H.W.
Bush? Yep. Nope. That's. That's also very,
very bad. He can't be trusted either.
Speaker 3: George H.W. Bush took millions
of documents to a former bowling alley
and a former Chinese restaurant where
they combine them. So they're in a
bowling alley slash Chinese restaurant.
Speaker 1: Okay. Now, that story, of course,
wasn't true, as you might imagine. What actually
happened was that the National Archives
rented a facility which previously was a
laundry and Chinese restaurant. The documents
were under the right possession and supervised
at all points. It just is not even remotely
analogous. But he was bad. Okay. Remember
Trump's promise about documents in 2016.
Speaker 3: On political corruption?
We are going to restore honor to our
government, right? In my administration,
I'm going to enforce all laws concerning laws,
the protection of classified information.
No one will be above the law.
Speaker 1: No one other than,
I guess, Trump himself. It sort of seems
also Trump saying he is better than Obama,
Bush and Clinton when it comes to documents.
Speaker 3: They've been given all the time. These
are other presidents all the time needed because
you're supposed to have as much time as you need
and complete deference when it came to their
documents and their papers. Take as much as
you need. Barack Hussein Obama moved more than 20
truckloads, over 33 million pages of documents,
both classified and unclassified, to a poorly
built and totally unsafe former furniture
store located in a rather bad neighborhood
in Chicago with no security, by the way.
George W Bush stored 68 million pages in a
warehouse in Texas and lost 22 million White House
emails. He lost 22 million emails. Can you imagine
if I lost two emails that say, this is terrible,
it must have been nuclear in those two. Correct.
Speaker 1: So you get it trumps the best at
everything all the time. It will be interesting if
we ever do find out exactly everything Trump stole
on his way out. Are there still missing documents
even after this particular find? And we have a
situation apparently here in the United States
where top secret documents, intelligence, it
seems quite poorly managed to the point where this
can even happen. Like there's there's two sides,
of course, to all of this Trump insanity on the
one hand. No one has really tested our systems the
way that Donald Trump has tested them. And so him
doing this stuff is wacky. But also, some of the
systems haven't worked particularly well. It's odd
that agencies didn't necessarily know about every
single one of these documents as soon as they were
missing. Oh, some turned up in a storage unit.
All right. I can't wait for the defense of this,
because it always boils down to incompetence. And
there was someone else pointing fingers. And also,
this isn't really a bad thing. And also Obama did
it worse and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Speaker 3: Oh, bum.
Speaker 1: Now, yeah, that guy, you remember
him? I don't know what the next step is on
the classified documents, but like we said, after
the Mar a Lago stuff happened that was not going
to be the last we heard about documents
and indeed more have already turned up.